friends my name is Jason Silva and we
are living in interesting times it is
2023 and we are spawning a new kind of
synthetic intelligence a new kind of
artificial sentience we're living
through a transformative shift in our
co-evolution with technology for the
first time in human history we have
technology that can converse with us it
is a phase change in human evolution in
the co-evolution of humans and
technology and it is the moment where a
new feedback loop is being
Unleashed a new feedback loop where we
are conversing and therefore thinking
with another kind of sentience with a
kind of synthetic intelligence that
works in ways we don't fully understand
but something to do with a neural net
the point is we are creating a new kind
of plasticity in the way that we
communicate with our own Creations it's
giving us a whole new set of
philosophical issues to contend with
what will be the unintended
side effects the unintended consequences
of this new coupling of humans and
thinking machines will we unleash a
Utopia Beyond human imagination will we
finally solve cancer will we turn
biology into a programmable medium and
learn to fold new kinds of protein
configurations that heal us but all of
our illnesses all of our diseases and
all of our suffering will we literally
Park the Seas of our own ignorance and
open up the cosmos will we go
Interstellar by deciphering new
mathematical equations that describe the
substrate of space and time using these
non-biological intelligence that can
literally perform more calculations per
second than we could ever dream is this
all going to speciate us into the next
realm the kind of growtopian Ideal with
Kevin Kelly and other thinkers dream
about where we become our imagination
where the imagination summons its own
literalizations it could go this way
friends it could go this way but we
could also things up why because
this Edward a Wilson
said we have arrived at a turning point
in our Evolution he says we have
Paleolithic brains unfortunately we have
medieval laws that the noble as they may
seem they can't keep up and then we have
god-like technology you know it's like
Stuart Branson we are as gods and might
as well get good at it but what happens
if we don't right with great power comes
great responsibility and you would hope
comes great wisdom but we lack the
necessary wisdom so we need a whole
Collective ship the whole planetary
shift we need to see the pale blue
thought we used to see ourselves in a
kind of shared identity we need to
assume a new narrative that propels us
all forward to stop the fighting stop
the politics stop the misinformation the
disinformation the fake news unify
together under the idea that we are star
makers spawning a new kind of digital
intelligence that will unleash new
possibilities that are beyond what we
can conceive we must come together under
this narrative or we will face the
consequences of which we can bear rarely
imagine we are at an existential fork in
the road whereby the future of what it
means to be humans is up for grabs it is
an opportunity for us to rise to the
occasion to step into our Interstellar
Destiny or become but a cautionary tale
and other intelligences across the
cosmos look upon as What Might Have Been
if we didn't things up so that's
where we are today a moment of
existential consequence and that is my
invitation to all of you to get with the
program to wake yourselves up from your
fractures and your the stories that no
longer sustain you to craft the new
Mythos together all of us now
and lean into our power and lean into
our possibility
because
We Are The Music Makers and we are the
dreamers of dreams like The Poets like
oshana say said like many others have
said it's a chance for us to lean into
our noblest and greatest impulses and
possibilities
so get on board
[Music]